une rencontre à peine terminée
depuis le 11 juin avec 5 crayons par
jour on a
a beaucoup qui
n'arrive la parole est plus facile à
recueillir pour tenter de convaincre les
grands électeurs ils vont visiter
275 communes dans une voiture
transformée en bureau quand on part on a
une fiche on est organisé on sait ce
qu'on va faire des kilomètres de route
c'est sûr que c'était là
avec un objectif pour le duo elle est
ressortant être réélu tous les deux il y
a cinq sièges à pourvoir en Isère la
répartition se fait à la proportionnelle
en fonction des scores obtenus par
chaque liste si on fait cette campagne
d'aller rencontrer d'essayer de
rencontrer le maximum de grands
électeurs c'est bien qu'on en a pas la
prétention de dire qu'on est sûr d'être
élu et après on verra le score des
différents disques leur avantage ils
peuvent défendre un bilan et compter sur
le soutien de la région et du
département à droite leur point faible
plusieurs grosses communes ont basculé à
gauche en 2020 mais ce n'est pas tout
face à eux l'écologie de Guillaume
Gontard vient de réussir un petit
exploit unir plusieurs force de gauche
derrière lui il y a la communiste
Frédéric penaver et le socialiste Erwan
Binet parce que les élus attendent c'est
de la responsabilité de la
responsabilité dans une période qui est
complexe sur lequel on a besoin de peser
besoins de peser au Sénat besoin de
renforcer le pôle écologiste et de
gauche au Sénat et on a actuellement 92
parlementaires de gauche et écologiste
nous notre ambition c'est de faire
passer au-delà de 100 et donc voilà moi
c'est ça qui m'anime et c'est ça qui
m'anime avec l'ensemble de mes
colystères et colistiers même si tout le
monde en convient les chances de gagner
trois sièges à gauche sont extrêmement
minces d'autant que Jean-Yves brognier
salut toi le maire de leyrieux au nord
du département se présente en dissident
apparemment on a la deuxième manche on
est en train de perdre c'est vrai
certains y voit un match à distance
entre Christophe Ferrari le président
socialiste de la métropole grenobloise
qui le soutient et Eric Piol le maire
écologiste de Grenoble qui soutient
l'autre liste mais Jean-Yves brognier
sans défend s'il y avait eu des
oppositions locales qui étaient à
l'initiative finalement de cette liste
Christophe Ferrari serait premier de la
liste le fait de pouvoir construire
cette proposition
alternative c'est surtout le fruit d'un
travail collectif parce qu'on a aussi
estimé qu'il était nécessaire que toute
l'Isère soit représentée et on sent bien
qu'à un manque de représentation au
niveau sénatorial dans le Nord-Isère un
éparpillement des voies qui pourrait
aider Didier Rambaud sénateur de la
majorité présidentielle
il patient dans cette campagne des liens
distendus entre Emmanuel Macron et les
élus je veux pas me cacher tout le monde
le sait voilà j'étais en Isère le
premier partant derrière Emmanuel Macron
le premier marcheur comme on dit donc
voilà pas me défiler oui c'est clair que
j'ai pas le vent dans le dos comme on
dit mais bon les élus locaux le sable
mais je pense qu'ils ont aussi besoin
parmi les sept les cinq sénateurs
d'avoir un sénateur de la majorité
présidentielle de son handicap il tente
donc de faire une force à la différence
de ces opposants il a selon lui
l'oreille du président pour faire
remonter les problématiques iseroises un
atout précieux qui pourrait peut-être le
hic vers un second mandat
et on va regarder l'ensemble des listes
qui ont été déposées en Isère cinq
sièges sont à pourvoir dans ce
département je vous rappelle que cette
élection sénatoriale se déroulera le
dimanche 24 septembre prochain on
regarde ensemble et candidats voilà et
on va continuer à parler
[Musique]